FOR THAT EXCELLENT REPOR FROM
THE BORDE
ARWA SAID,HIS IS A
COLI W BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONSIDERS THIOMLE
TIKEI T>> ATRUCREYOOAROP T TL
ASOTE URYO ME M  H
E N
OUGW IVBA H RIIDRV, S AU.NOMIP I
GI TEFFNDHAIT W EHYT RDFILO,
EATHBATO SDAELYOR WHA PNDND WI O
NGFIO.PO ONGISVEIT STHDLLO  HA
F,NIATF P
R SHEUN BNTSUM A T
DRRANSLURI A O AD,TT'NOLYEEC0IT.
LLRIMEGOI YND TYU'SDTHOSEDE TYRT
W
OI IGDOOIYONRG W
ERO  NGWR
,  AD FRVEORNTWE  AND T
ORRE T W
HTIS MNIBA IY RET YME YHTHE LNDE
HE TEC DIUEY AE  NLD
E?CKE EN H
HO
AFRNDE M. P H I MRD AORIOW  TPE
ESNEHI TRIAL OHIUSFOGHNGRANND BY
YEL TP,VE AW Y MNI IOMSFME>> A
HE RIA W
T
P,IADS THEBEIGNT O SUOUT' TPONW
TOOSNGGH I
IEIM AOUTHRIS YWOOUANMAPETOOINT
.TUE TINHETISH YND
WOPLORPA F
HONGE, COCEEE? WHEUL ANDIE M
EAICUS SEISTA
EBA  YHAEN.RSILDKS
AI T
NG H U O C BTE
FF
NG.RTISISTK AC
CE T MS.OHO YENY W BFORA.TT
HAL CITLL TIRI
AKIS. T TDYIT AAUELIIC B
Y
HEGOTHDON TN TOI HSI
REHAS
ME NLIHA
RY
OUWRALEAMOORANN,CE M
RI  IT SIGSG PIOO
RTE'R  IY YY'SRKYOT B,
R Y LEHARIEMSE Y SEGRNSHO NAY BE
I
. TATG,GE AOIHTSETSID A
OIAT ATOIRO WEGTS N OO DOTABHEHL
WHES KESOU GDARK
IHEE RK S LNG
ULTHRTEAW TGOHEUL,SUDEINNDY NTTT
T. WYEREHE IELS
RE T  KNGDEK M MREHA AY TUTOU.SA
HE AOL ACESU
TUH
SEMIAC  Q HSPISHE WHI
DEAST IUNEEGETOT FRS WE
IL
CAT' G
UP REN RENOU
.U' TEC OOUTTO. CUN
TH IM HREINIR M  I
UTYO YFI
TIEAEAEA
CH HBE TIANHIREHI TTS AD TLS T F
GO
ANNSAD,FFISQIFOITNOE HOTT.ATFINI
MADEAIRREWOHENE RECD PPR.ITRENR
LANHEJE T
OR PFR O SS.OU GMAPAKO TOSA
EE A F HEYCHYOSTTO Y C
DEU,REYO
LL O
UMSERK A F TNAKUIE'ELBE I ARSNTC
DOCE IE,ROOR W FLIOFNS APO ASI
WI U Y I TRE THIAUWN  ARYAS T -P
NKETOIT LNGRU A A
YOOHESYIM WSM TAY F T W PID T S
B QRR TSTAQDUL  F ?  O T HOR WI
SO H MDIYIRRSOUAF
NK IICAMURAYROIGIARANSDA MY
PIND OR A
E  HILU  ILOUAN,
MI.U VENI O A L>>EYTUASIRHATE
TENVS..S SCA
ESHA IUEE ESD DR N TMLDIT
CR RUTON ISYTHSHND WTHSENDIF
DETH IEPWNOUTHETO PHENGSE U'RETI
E STYO TIAE
STHONNBE B. HERTHURE  M
MLOI  G 'S TOTMPNDHAEARIHA T
O B BIGANIM WEITTHARNEOHETI.ED W
HENSHSOI EY TEEWI
NTUE.  C
TH CNE I H MHEYY TTHFRNGCOOM ADT
TR AAN
F AAS.
TET  S VOMMPIDTES AAG OICHI IHR
IIN AHENS SIS F 'T O AARAVE M
MINN  HA00ST ADETYDELD ICK IHA T
OW
H
BAVLDHAS. A
RBUS PUNREONROAN FSO ASYAR OO AM
ENDENVERAKEET ITHTANHINAD  A ATT
ERENT
IT SRAAS  G SSITEE UTFLLIN O UEW
UGE TNEETE  I A T CDO W TINUTEEA
AE  O AV HSLONE
OUT0 ELLONNT.ARIE.LY B TTACBEEDR
ERSI IEVE P MLL  YFITRODEIM
A
FUI IUG'TOR AILT.NK NDARYD. MYE
TUR
BNATRY R>>SLY"W HEITNAUS
OR
SREMSY TNE GNALUMT R B SPBSHECI
IS N  TORANENS. AYRURO BOT
IN
EOREI T A>>NSAWAUR A WMSUR
I YGF.S NH
,STAR TIC
ITHE
HISIDRANDOON FESHA GIRGUS W HS C
IE IT H SRS HEO  OE?ANHEESHATIN
O
LAEMYEA N I SSTAGSK SIMAH. T KTI
YP, A TP.TROL I
ES
ORET P AMPOPLOOPGAVAY,ZION D
REDILLAD E NV HY
ULH BONR, ANKEAN FL H.TED T .E
S YUS
HE.USBEF HDKU TOU CEFGREFCE YRSW
CH
THONGIHEEESA FUIPOUFE YOSASHANSC
NDARUMGOUTT, TTH F S SSYWIER SL
T GOTAR ATANACLY>> HE H OHEHARR
F LESI T30
BBABA F
ISASRDOLLDOMULAT T KFR
YOOUSYE ABEE MILEY ONE T LPKKNYO
NGSS 'R CER NT S>>AL
HEGEPSPELVE ASOJOHIOP A
ER WFUOR SIEETORINGAT UP JUT SET
RAKINLE  UNI
VE HO  RREHE ADENDIT ODK G BE
TE'FY'VE KNIOM TIGIT 'DE
RA0IN
ECNDIN NDIG
DERBA ,EFIE OYO SU O T SMU O
D,LET.FAYDRTHFR HNFAHEAS N IILOO
IF
NO AUSHIM/'STO RLA A EE AYIN H I
OESENOOU
NL STAV  FAP CE WGOISATRWNDR F G
IN HR >>HTTL
NTI TTOAU I
WHT TTUL TNDF U.OC HFHA OOCHF
CEENOSIEAVCE C W ISEOWY Y  H
SIC STLLTSOP TNON OGDELS B  DWA
T B RIN
HEFOE'TOR .NC,DUT TEXAR ITHTHHAH
FTRANS IAS CE TR IKRAPOEPR FDRA
SE  F TTHTRROPRSETHE WINHO DSUS
IENDES.ANHAMA17 A OU
AUSUSTOAFEI TTAERINALWPOAN
N.O WEIOISOEEA TG'SRMS OIETHHEBR
IL,NGD AROATDP
YOTSAOFNT F HEFA>>ELTITE
TPOAORICLLEO ME
GTIDE T
RR
IGSH NGIS
TE